[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
were riders who stormed the capitol
building trained and organized
seemingly with the intent to capture the
vice president of the united states
our interview with the attorney for one
of the suspects accused of leaving a
threatening message
plus the daring lengths one photographer
went to capture
incredible images while he's now facing
even more charges for them
and a deadly police encounter captured
on camera a family calls for justice
after a black man was killed in front of
his own home law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
federal authorities are trying to keep
suspects in the storming of the u.s
capitol building
locked behind bars angela levy has more
on what we've learned about the deadly
insurrection
yeah brian we have some new information
that prosecutors are outlining in a
brief they are allegations against jacob
chansley who's also known as the q anon
shaman the government has filed an
18-page
brief that lays out why they believe
chansley should remain in jail
federal prosecutors say chansley is an
active participant in and has made
himself the most prominent symbol of a
violent insurrection
that attempted to overthrow the united
states government
it goes on to say that chansley has
expressed interest in returning to d.c
for
president-elect joe biden's inauguration
photos in the brief
show chansley with a bullhorn and
prosecutors say chansley actually left a
note for vice president pence saying
quote
it's only a matter of time justice is
coming
now joining me now is alfred watkins he
is the attorney for
jacob chansley one of the attorneys mr
watkins thanks so much for joining us
today
it's my pleasure so you've been quoted
as saying that you believe president
trump
should issue a pardon to your client why
do you believe that's necessary or
it should happen so i don't think
anybody in a million years
myself included are holding their breath
to believe
that uh at some point along the line
president trump will say you know what i
want to pardon
i want to pardon the guy with horns and
a fur
wrap the fact of the matter is the
purpose of this
exercise with seeking the pardon from
president trump was in effect
dealing with addressing a long-standing
relationship that my client had with the
president
in my client's mind and for him to get
past
the reality of the perceived betrayal
by the president of our client his
simple
thought process was you know give the
president
a chance to do the honorable thing so
when we reach out to the president and
say
through the white house press not press
secretary but chief of staff mark
meadows
hey look we we'd like a pardon i'm not
sitting here holding my breath i've told
my client not to hold my breath
but what this does is it permits my
client to
come to the stark reality that he
while he may have been duped by the
president while he may have believed
that he was doing what the president
invited him to do the president isn't
on his side the nation is not on his
side
and he's going to have to stand up or
belly up to the bar
and ultimately hold himself accountable
for what his role is
the dialogue i'm trying to start here is
to keep this from being a lynch mob
mentality mr watkins i want to play a
clip of president trump from january 6
and then we're going to talk about it on
the other side
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're gonna walk
down
to the capitol
because you'll never take back our
country with weakness
you have to show strength and you have
to be strong
mr watkins um in listening to that clip
and there were some other clips from
that day
the president never instructed your
client to go down there and walk into
the capitol
in fact the president actually said at
one point he wanted people to be
peaceful and for their voices to be
heard
so where is the connection here the
president never told your client to make
those choices he made this choice all
right so you listen to the words that
the president said
i listen to the words that the president
said and we hear
perhaps the same words but you have to
contextualize them
within the heart and mind of those who
listened to
and acted on those words we're talking
about not
not just the guy with the horns and the
hair
the tattoos the bare chest the
the shaman we're talking about
thousands of people who they felt
they heard the message to them from
their
president was we're going to walk down
to the capitol
no the president didn't say
hey look we're going to walk down the
capitol we're going to play
tiddlywinks or we're going to go into
the capital
ourselves and we're going to get this
done hyperbole is used
innuendo is used but it doesn't matter
my client which was against the law
but he did so within the context of this
dynamic
but your client made that choice what
was his intention in entering the
capitol
have you ever been to a high school game
right before the game the coach has the
team in the locker room and he's hyping
them up to
race out in the field that's what was
done
our president is a very excellent
motivator for those who are receiving
his message
he now you're your client he succeeded
in no small part because he talked to
and identified people whose voice had
not been heard for way too long
but your client also called this a win
because the traders were in their
offices
hunkering down with gas masks on does
your client
actually believe these people are
traitors he also called
vice president pence he told the fbi he
was a child trafficking trader which
we've never seen any evidence of
does your client actually believe these
things well i don't think we've seen
any evidence of voter fraud i don't
think we've seen
any evidence of you know a child a child
porn ring i you know there is an
alternate universe that happens to exist
in this world
and sometimes some people embrace it and
they move forward with it
and they have an issue my client perhaps
happens to
it doesn't take much to look at my
client and say you know what
maybe just maybe he doesn't fall within
the bell curve of that which you and i
would consider normal
and the fbi has said there was a plot to
assassinate the feds are now walking
back that claim what's your response to
that
so who's walking back what claim there's
a lot of activity that's going on
so help me out specifically yeah the fbi
is walking back
the claim or at least the u.s attorney
in the district of columbia is walking
back the claim that
people were trying to assassinate
members of congress
in the capitol building that's been some
news that's been breaking just here in
the last
what's your response to that yeah well
here's here's part of the issue and i'm
really respectful of the
assistant u.s attorney that's involved
in this the fact is he's having to do
with deal with a lot of moving targets
in addition to
media inquiries and of course the
political ramifications that are going
on
he has to deal with special agents
investigative officers and
agents and the reports that are coming
in with them and
so is he walking it back out he's doing
the responsible thing
because he knows that his duty is
justice
mr watkins we're going to have to cut it
off there we thank you so much for
joining us and we will continue to
follow this case
brian thank you very much thank you
thank you angela and mr watkins but
don't go anywhere because still ahead on
law and crime daily our experts are
standing by
to react to what attorney al watkins
just said
plus the brave actions of a capitol
police officer
how congress is looking to honor his
action after the break
[Music]
take a look at these faces the new york
times is reporting the fbi is now
investigating 37 people
for the death of capitol police officer
brian siknik
including some of the suspects shown
here
and ahead of the presidential
inauguration investigators are
monitoring possible threats
in online chat rooms we have a daily
download
with the fbi we brief the mayor
daily just on the information that's out
there
and i can assure the residents of the
district of columbia that the
metropolitan
police department and our federal
partners
are in a posture to respond to the to
the information that's out there thus
far
that we've heard one officer's actions
are standing out from the january 6
riots
terry austin has the latest on a plan to
honor him for his bravery
brian a bipartisan group of lawmakers
want to recognize a capitol police
officer with a gold medal for his quick
thinking that likely saved lives
officials say officer eugene goodman
tricked a group of riders who had broken
into the building
goodman seeing the door to the senate
chamber was opened
pushed one of the rioters getting the
mob to follow him
up another flight of stairs the group
was led to
a hallway where more officers were
waiting as a backup
joining us now is retired nypd detective
term professor kirk burkhalter
along with terry austin terry you've got
a question for the professor
yes kirk i wanted to know it appears
that this might be
one thing that gets bipartisan support
what are your thoughts
on the move to honor officer goodman
oh i think it's an excellent move the
officer here showed an amazing level of
situational awareness
and more than likely prevented further
harm
or even loss of life uh the
fbi uh latest reports not withstanding
we certainly know that folks
did intend in some way shape or form to
at least uh take hostages
about as evidenced by the zip ties and
other materials they had
so he did a tremendous job thought on
his feet
uh it's an honor that would be well
deserved i would agree with you there
professor burkhalter now terry i got a
question for you 37 suspects in the
killing of a single officer
how's prosecuting that case going to
look you know brian it's not going to be
easy i suspect they're going to be
a multitude of motions to join the cases
by the prosecuting attorneys and motions
to
sever the cases by the defense attorneys
the prosecutors are going to
argue that the cases involve the same
set of facts and circumstances
and that they will be able to save
resources but you know the defense
attorneys are definitely going to argue
that combining these cases will
prejudice
their individual clients so i think
we're going to see a
bevy of motions prior to trial all right
let's talk about what defensive attorney
al watkins just spoke about
uh professor burkhalter we heard him
describe his client as like
maybe not being what we would describe
as normal and that in his
mind when we contextualized this all
that he believed the officer was
inviting him
into the capital to fight for the
election
could that be a possible defense here in
his case
i i actually don't see how you know if
you think about the impeachment
proceedings they were based on the fact
that congress argued that the
president's uh
rhetoric was reckless and here
in some way shape or form the
defendant's attorney is stating that
he was invited in and it sounds kind of
good in an
academic setting but i don't think it
will fly uh
in a court setting and i you know don't
know if he was
setting up a little bit of an insanity
defense here and that might be a
possibility
all right so maybe this would work on
one of professor burkhalter's law school
exams but maybe not in the courtrooms
i'll see how that works out
exactly and terry there's a potential
for felony murder charges here
for these 37 people right absolutely you
know we had a capitol police officer who
was
killed any one of these individuals who
was involved
in breaking in and anywhere near that
police officer
could be charged with murder if in fact
they contributed to
his death all right so we've got 37
suspects we've got the q and on shaman
getting his organic meals we're going to
keep an eye on this case as it develops
thank you both for contributing coming
up on law and crime daily why the
attorney general of new york is suing
police
over protest but first an update in the
case of a photographer arrested for
taking these
daring photos what new charges he's
facing after the break
[Music]
an army veteran who's been traveling the
country taking extreme risk to take
photos
now faces more charges anjanet levy has
an update on the law and crime exclusive
yeah brian we first told you about isaac
wright also known on the internet as
drifter shoots earlier this month
he was charged with breaking into an
office building in cincinnati but now
he's also charged with breaking into a
major league baseball ballpark
writes photos posted on social media and
on his website where he sells them
he was honorably discharged from the
army in april of last year
and started scaling towers buildings and
bridges to take
photos a grand jury in cincinnati has
now indicted wright on two counts of
burglary
one count of possession of criminal
tools and inducing panic
prosecutors say wright broke into the
great american ballpark where the
cincinnati reds play last november
and that he used a lock pick set and pry
bar to break into an office building
nearby
leading to an eight-hour lockdown of
that building and search
but wright maintains he didn't break
into anything and his supporters have
posted on his instagram account
asking them to call the prosecutor's
office to protest the charging decision
obviously they aren't privy to all of
the evidence that we have
nor even some of the statements that
have been made by mr wright so
i understand there's there's always
sentiment for
defendants and victims alike on any
criminal case so that's just their
perspective
but we reviewed all of the evidence
available and there were there was
evidence to support the charges
burglary is really a trespass with a
purpose to commit an offense
inside the facility or home if it is a
home in this case we didn't charge a
home
uh just entering with purpose to commit
some criminal offense
in this instance it's criminal trespass
and so uh
it fits the statute and so that's why
it's charged as a burglary
wright's lawyer lawrence haas issued a
statement to us
it reads commenting on any specifics
without reviewing state's evidence
would not make sense at this point in
the case we do see a lot of similarities
between the allegations against
isaac and the protest in 2014 at png
done by greenpeace international luckily
we have the case president
in that matter to hold all parties to a
consistent resolution
now those protesters in that case they
actually ended up
being charged with burglary but pleaded
guilty to a trespassing charge
isaac wright is also facing a felony
trespassing charge
in detroit michigan he is accused of
climbing a bridge and taking photos
there
brian thanks anjanet
when we come back a deadly police
shooting in texas the video that
captures a man
answering his door then later being shot
by an officer
why his family is calling for the
officer's arrest next
welcome back new york's attorney general
is suing new york city and
its police department for what she calls
excessive force and false arrests
during black lives matter protest
we found that over the course course of
the protest from may
to december of 2020 nypd officers
engaged in blatant use of
excessive force and often misconduct
including the
indiscriminate unjustified and repeated
use of batons
pepper spray bicycles
and a crowd-controlled tactic known as
kettling
also referred to as containment
which caused significant physical harm
i want to tell you about another
incident the type that happens
far too often and what many protesters
are fighting for
killing texas police officer reynaldo
contreras
responded to a call for psychiatric help
on january 10th
52 year old patrick warren senior
answered the door
police say warren was emotionally
distressed the officer deployed his
taser
but it reportedly was ineffective that's
when police say
officer fired killing warren attorney
lee merritt
is representing warren's family and
released video of the incident
captured on the family's ring doorbell
and cell phone
a warning to some viewers this may be
disturbing
[Music]
okay
hey hey hey dad sit down sit down
sit down sit down please
[Music]
no i told you don't use a gun i told you
i told you don't use the gun
with me are the professor and terry kirk
you've got the experience of an nypd
officer and the knowledge
of a professor how do you view this
police shooting
well it evidence is once again that we
don't have a
national standard on how we treat those
who are under mental distress
and it needs to be corrected this tends
to happen to
african americans more than others and
further
in this instance i believe uh you know
there wasn't a resource
officer available or something that
respect you know this has to be a
priority across our country
how many videos must we see of unarmed
people in mental distress being uh the
victims of deadly physical force
at the hands of law enforcement
something must
absolutely change absolutely terry
once again it's a person of color once
again it's an emotionally distressed
person
once again officers are not prepared to
interact with a person
and now a man is dead what are your
thoughts when you first heard this story
brian when i first heard this my
reaction
was just like the family's reaction i
said no
no no this can't be possibly happening
again but it is and it won't be the last
time
i mean according to the washington post
989 people were shot and killed by
police in 2020 and blacks were killed
at a rate of twice the amount and many
of them
were unarmed and until we
get some training here we will continue
to see this
until police officers understand
that just because you are a person of
color it doesn't mean
that you are a threat and yes they
should have had
someone who was trained as far as
responding to someone with mental
illness we knew that this individual
had mental illness and so this should
not have happened
now kirk you touched on this a little
bit but according to the story the day
before
they called for a resource officer that
resource officer showed up
brought him to the hospital and it all
works so why did it fail
here why can't we get it right
well it failed here because the
administration uh the
the power structure there and that
particular municipality
has not taken this as a priority it must
be a priority
when you send a police officer who is
not trained
to a situation like this this is
something that's likely to happen
thanks kirk thank terry and thank you
for joining us here we'll see you next
time we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you